what I do every time I'm out and I have
my laser I flash it at a star that's in
the night sky
like a like a pulse and then I turn it
off so if you leave the light on for one
second right there's a beam that's 186
000 miles long
right okay and so that is on its way to
that to that star it may be to a planet
that'll see it it's so cool yeah that's
just my it's my space graffiti I'd say
Neil is here
[Music]
this is Star Talk Cosmic queries fan
favorite Cosmic queries and this is the
grab bag Edition Chuck you ready for it
always loving a grab bag yeah yeah the
grab bags are fun because they're just
they're like random you know they just
dance around that's it and they keep me
on my toes I slide I haven't seen these
questions so you have the random beauty
of a snowfall
I don't know what that means at all you
never know what you're going to get but
you know it's going to snow okay okay
so at your attempted poetry okay get a c
plus on that one all right all right
give them to me Chuck let's go right
this is uh Bjorn
he says we seem to focus for obvious
reasons on the what and the how of the
universe the why never seems to get much
scientific attention because it assumes
I imagine that there is a purpose which
physics does not really need with that
in mind
it's not the why an important factor for
human curiosity and should we not then
seek to not necessarily find a reason
for the universe but encourage those who
seek purpose and thus understanding
hey I am it's philosophical and just at
this time of the morning
so hey
so you don't need a y is what I'm saying
but shouldn't we still ask why all right
so
I have a response for that okay I've
thought deeply about this by the way I
know I have so uh in physics
we declare full understanding of
something
when we can account for all the behavior
we've seen at exhibit and predict all
future behavior that it might undergo
and we know what it'll do when we poke
it when we heat it when we freeze it and
we say we understand this thing I know
what you did last time I Know What You
Did Last I know what you will do so
let's take gravity for an example okay
so you can say well what is gravity how
does gravity work and then you say well
Y is gravity you can let's go in this
sequence I suppose and I'm I will I'm
here to tell you that we can launch
space probes from Earth a moving Target
and hit
a moonlit around an asteroid
Point Blank
having sent a space probe to where it
will would be when they both got to the
same point at the same time
yes it is rocket science yes it is
involved a precise understanding of
gravity
we're good with that
if you want to try to Now understand
why
you know why did the why did the
spacecraft hit its Target mm-hmm because
we did the calculations and we gave it
the right acceleration and we knew where
the target was when it was going to get
there that's why it hit I love it by the
way which one
Why did the
nevermind I'm sorry
why'd the asteroid cross the road
because the way you said it was like why
did the chicken cross it and then your
answer was because we did the
calculation and we saw exactly where it
was going to hit like
my favorite answer to why did the
chicken cross the road is
um can't can't a chicken cross the road
without having its motives questioned
every time
okay let me give you the black version
of that no yeah why did the chicken
cross the road why are you in my
business
who asked you exactly
all right
why that's why that's why
oh all right so so so the the point is
you can say let's say uh you the pie is
up on a table and it falls to the ground
right you say why did The Pie fall to
the ground and I could say well because
you pushed it right that should be
sufficient response to that why question
okay well you pushed it but there's a
little more going on if we were floating
in space and you pushed it it wouldn't
fall at all
because there's no net gravity Vector
there that will have the thing fall
it'll just when it's in free fall it'll
just float okay so so there are plenty
of questions where the Y is a completely
satisfactory answer
we can give you a why for it okay
um why were you T-boned at the
intersection
because you ran the light
okay
there is no end of questions for which
the why there's no end of situations for
which the why question has a completely
legitimate answer that we're all
satisfied with right okay yes it becomes
an issue if you try to get take a
philosophical step and then try to
explore why as the consequence of intent
gotcha in so doing you are handing
intent to things that might have no
intent at all
and therefore you are forcing an intent
where there might not have otherwise
been one
and therefore you're forcing an answer
and now you're chasing ghosts at that
point
right
he answered his question and you just
confirmed it he said it's not necessary
so basically what you're saying is for
the purposes of science if what we're
really concerned about is science we
don't need that well or I have answers
that are science that are satisfactory
answers the question why I don't and I
should have said that too I don't need
to go beyond that because the science
has been satisfied
you're satisfied because I have a
scientific answer for why something
happened right okay why is Earth warming
because we are adding greenhouse gases
to the chemical mixture of the
atmosphere right that is a complete
contained answer to the question why
so I will not
exceed the accusation that science is
not about why I will not say that right
there are plenty of why questions where
we are all completely content with the
scientific answer for it right and so
there you go and like you said going
beyond that you're creating a dragon and
then chasing the dragon you created the
dragon correct you created the dragon
and now you're chasing them and you want
to give meaning and significance to the
existence of the Dragon you created
where there was never a dragon there to
begin with there you go well look at
that Bjorn you started off by saying
that you were going to ask a profound
question I gotta give it to you but what
I do want to say is go ahead if you're
going to say well
because one of them is what is the
meaning of life that's not a y question
that's a one okay and I might say the
meaning is the what you make of it
given that you have power over objects
and events and things and places and
people in your influence you can create
meaning rather than just simply look for
it
most people are looking for meaning like
it's under a rock or behind a tree right
and they spend their whole lives in
search of meaning and I'm saying
make the meaning
and derive your meaning from that okay
now you might say well why should we
have meaning in life
I would say
in our experience people with more
meaning in the Life lead a more
fulfilled life and to be fulfilled is in
our short time on Earth maybe something
we should all seek so you can have a
better child why do you want a better
time you could keep doing this yes but I
would ask you what is the end game of
that
where will you be satisfied with your
sequence of asking why because if you're
never satisfied then you're not useful
on the moving Frontier of science where
we can land a Target
moving in space right here we can take
pictures of the early Universe in a
telescope parked a million miles in in
orbit around Earth a million miles from
Earth called the James Webb Space
Telescope
while you're asking questions we are
answering questions
while you're asking why questions in the
dragon that you just created we are
answering questions and advancing
civilization so uh yes I am discounting
many people who are asking why about
many things but so many other things
where you ask a why
the answer when drawn from science or
even from culture or whatever is a
perfectly satisfactory answer that no
one would further question well there
you have it that was very very necessary
yeah all of that that you just said very
very necessary I mean it speaks to so
many other things than just this
question from Bjorn there's so much yeah
it does it's it's a it's it it stretches
yeah beyond the limits of the question
itself yes wonderful wow good stuff keep
it coming here we go here we go let's go
to our next one which is J salmon
um or is it salmon I don't know I don't
know anybody who pronounces the L and
salmon neither do I yeah it's ridiculous
it's Salmon well it's salmon Rusty right
I mean salmon yeah yeah okay so he says
when matter is consumed by the black
hole does it retain its form as protons
neutrons
Etc
or is it compressed and ripped apart
to the more basic elements of the
particles like quarks Etc I can answer
that very clear we don't know
next question there you go let's move on
no no so
um matter and all the identity it
carries as it goes down to the singular
it's the singularity where where just it
we're idiots that's that that's unfair
it's a singularity where we have
profound ignorance all right right and
Einstein's
theory of relativity which gives us the
black hole in the first place does not
take us to the singularity it's a limit
to the theory of relativity that's why
we have string theorists who are picking
up the slack there we do not know what
happens to matter at the singularity
we just don't
we do know that the black hole remembers
what it ate
because Hawking radiation where
particles come into existence from the
energy of its gravitational field
just outside the Event Horizon
that gravitational energy through equals
mc squared spontaneously becomes a pair
of particles
one side of that particle falls back in
the other side escapes
if you get the inventory of the
particles created out of the
gravitational energy field that
inventory of particles exactly equals
the history of what the black hole ate
remarkably
somehow the imprint of what it ate is
Remembered in the gravitational field
of the black hole itself yes that's
pretty well that's pretty profound it's
profound yes wild because you didn't
reach back in and pull it out no it was
here it appeared out of the the energy
outside the Event Horizon look at that
it's like oh my gosh and of course
Stephen Hawking was at the centerpiece
of that that's amazing Hawking radiation
rest in peace we actually had him on
start talk back when we were uh we were
on the National Geographic Channel yeah
and you might be able to dig it out in
in I guess Disney plus has the entire
netgeo catalog uh but yeah it's good
stuff man yeah that is good stuff all
right here we go Colby LA pressie from
South Carolina all right and Colby says
once again with the black holes if a
black hole was smaller than my body
Beyond The Event Horizon in all
directions
would it still rip me apart Adam by Adam
yes
don't ever no just stay away
because what matters is not the size of
the black hole how much mass so if Earth
were a black hole it would be the size
of a plung right so now take all the
mass of the Earth cram it into a plum
and you want to walk by it and believe
you're going to stay intact that is not
going to happen
it will suck you in and it will funnel
you down and you'll be spaghettified
funneled and that's it and just kiss
your ass goodbye look at that Colby
because you wonder how something your
size can fit into something that small
it's a very fabric of space-time
Narrows towards the black hole so you
will be funneled
basically extruded through the fabric of
space and time like toothpaste through a
tube that's crazy man when you think
about it it's yeah that's uh it's so
hard to just like really you to Fathom
it yeah to have a black hole that fits
in your palm of your hand and then it
sucks you down into a tiny point it's oh
I mean it's really it's It's oddly
terrifying and beautiful at the same
time yes yes yes
wow okay all right yeah you're not
getting out of that one keep your
distance
here Alan rayer Alan rayer says can
someone address uh the comet
c2022e3 hey Neil just wanna let you know
I'm a big fan and I'm coming to you from
the Isle of Malta oh my gosh cool well
when we come back from our first break
we will address that question on Star
Talk
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries grab
bag Edition we left off with someone
asking me about comment what's that what
number did that good man Alan rayer from
the island of Malta in the Mediterranean
once you know hey what's the deal with
the
c2022 E3 but he gave me the he gave me
the phone number the comment cool cool
so uh that's been called the Great green
Comet of 2023. by the way those that ID
is uh includes the year it was
discovered 2022 and the semi month it
was discovered so there's there's that
that idea is packed with information for
someone in the know to know when it was
discovered and so a b this comment based
on its orbit uh it comes from What's
called the work cloud
this is a this is a spherical shell of
comets that surrounds the solar system
but it extends halfway to the nearest
stars and comets that come from this can
come in from any direction at all yeah
they can Loop in from above from below
and their orbits last tens of thousands
of years there is no Comet that we see
from the Oort cloud that was ever seen
in the history of civilization
wow so you might say to yourself well I
better go out and watch it well every
word cloud comment is that so it's it's
possible for something to be rare but
uninteresting
okay because they're common right right
that's just just keep that in mind so uh
with this comment it's made the news
primarily because there's a chance
people could see it okay and right now
like last night it would be among the
days of peak visibility I looked up I
didn't see it I'd have to find it with
binoculars so it's got a lot of press
attention by the way we discover
hundreds of comments a year right so a
comet it alone is not some you know I
don't
invest special attention to the
existence to the fact that a comment was
discovered
they're as common as as Blades of grass
on a lawn there's trillions of them that
orbit the Sun so a b
the the many comments are very faint and
you might catch it with binoculars and
you can see the green in a telescope
because it's a green Comet remember our
retina has rods and cones yep and the
rods are sensitive to Shades of Gray the
cones are sensitive to color but they
require higher intensity light in order
to get triggered
so if you dim the lights in a room if
you look at a room in the dark but just
light leaking in from a street light
something through the window that room
is not vibrantly colored no it's
basically Shades of Gray okay because
your your your cones your rods are
taking care of business there just so
you can see your way anywhere only when
it gets brighter dead you start
registering the colors so dim comments
no matter what color they are in a
telescope typically you don't notice
that with your eyes unless you can see
them through a a big telescope okay they
can make the object bright enough to to
trigger your cones so way to get the
green from the green well we did an
explainer on the comment I think we did
yeah we did an explainer so uh Cyanogen
is one of the molecules that when it
interacts with sunlight gets warm we
radiate H light there are different ways
a comic is rendered visible and
different chemicals will have different
color signatures and that's part of what
tells us what comets are made of right I
mean it's a beautiful wonderful thing so
I love me some comments but most of them
are just not you know they're not
something you're going to write home
about and say were you alive in the 20th
yeah I promise in your lifetime we'll
have a really good comment because every
10 or 20 years or so a really good one
comes around I wouldn't count this among
them now the real deal is that the
action is where the asteroids are my
friend don't worry about the cops the
action is with the asteroids that's okay
yeah but asteroids are dark and they
only like reflect light right and
they're and even if they do reflect
their dark so they don't reflect much
light so they can come up on you and you
wouldn't know where's comets
yes exactly look at my tail look at my
beautiful yeah look at me looking me
asteroids are just like yo I said give
me your wallet
you said that way too glibly
give me your wallet
no the more likely the asteroids will
say yo give me all your species
about the wallet at that point yeah I'm
trying to figure out if there's ever an
asteroid big enough
that would blow off the
entire atmosphere because anything that
hits the atmosphere the atmosphere
becomes like like like like the ocean or
anything else it you know it would have
to be penetrated so you if suppose you
had something big enough that it hits
the atmosphere
but
it's so powerful that it blows the
atmosphere off
but with it
then be so big it would destroy the
planet
next question
right so now here's the thing oh yeah I
want to get rid of man that was cool I
know it was cool you want to get rid of
the atmosphere you you get enough
asteroids hitting Earth to heat the
atmosphere and the hotter atmosphere
expands and we might lose some outer
layers because yeah the molecules start
moving faster right and some will
achieve escape velocity right and so
um but the and a large enough ask for it
just punches a hole in the atmosphere
the real damage is because it doesn't
leave its energy in the atmosphere the
energy it'll barely be slowed down by
the atmosphere and then it hits Earth's
surface and that's where it stops moving
hey where did all the kinetic energy go
it made a crater it burned the forests
it
um it became a shock wave shock waves
that's so you have to ask where the
where look at the energy budget where
did it go that's where the damage will
occur okay cool man that was cool all
right here we go this is Nick Davis he
says hello uh Dr Tyson and Lord nice
um this is Nick from Australia I I was
wanting to know more about how gravity
and its influence on time were to
influence light
myler's planet and Interstellar what
would happen if someone orbiting outside
of the time Distortion were to point a
super powerful laser pointer at the
planet
would the beam be dimmer or with the
night sky look like for what would the
light night sky look like for someone on
the ground compared to someone in space
and let's take out atmosphere so that we
don't have those distortions right yes
so no we're good here so here's what
interesting to do with your laser the
next time you're trapped in a black hole
you can try to point your laser out of
the black hole and see if anybody gets
the signal they won't
all right why not because it's climbing
out of the gravitational well that the
black hole is and for every little bit
it ascends it's losing energy
so the energy profile of your laser will
become lower and lower and lower energy
until there's no energy left at all and
the light does not Escape
if you are just outside the Event
Horizon it did the same thing the light
would Escape but it would also be
shifted in energy and it's called a
gravitational redshift look at that
Gravity redshifts the light and so
that's that's what would happen to the
light to the this is only about lighter
do they also ask about time
well yeah so he started off saying
um I wanted to know about gravity and
its influence on time yeah so like and
and if he remembers from Interstellar
they're on a planet orbiting a black
hole right and they are severely time
dilated yeah so that minutes to them or
years to the folks orbiting far out
that's right that's that's the scene
where he comes back and the guy is old
right he's old correct wow correct and
uh it was subtle but they got it in
there at the end
the the the the
what was it the they showed someone in a
hospital bed or was it I forgot that was
his daughter that's who's older who was
older than he is correct correct because
his uh so so because his life was
prolonged for having been in a very
intense gravitational field right so
yeah all these are real and you can
calculate it and by the way we do this
every day with GPS satellites mm-hmm GPS
satellites are in a different
gravitational field compared with us
yes it's still Earth
but we are closer to Earth's center than
the GPS satellites are so just the way
they did in the movie Interstellar
except it's not a doesn't have to be a
black hole to mess with your time it
just will mess with it at a different
level at a lesser amount so our time on
Earth is ticking more slowly
than the time in GPS satellites right
and yeah is handing us our time right
wow so how is it that they match up we
have uh I don't know how I know how how
do they know because the GPS
um
they don't see Pita don't stop
see a lot of y'all don't know about it
okay all right thank you Chuck let's see
GPS y'all don't know stay down with CP
time and they cool they're cool
and I'm not going to explain what that
is okay Google CP time if you know what
it is you know what it is the Google CP
time all right so
Chuck I don't know
could still in race therapy
[Laughter]
this stuff all right so so the GPS
satellites are are no you're saying that
on Earth we'd be super time because the
GPS satellites being in a different
level yeah closer to the gravity so we
are slow we're slow GPS sound like is
ahead by a calculatable amount right and
so when it's gives us our time signature
signals it pre-corrects it using the
equations of Einstein's general theory
of relativity so that we get the proper
time on Earth surface that's that's just
ah I'm telling you this is fantastic
yeah yeah and and people say I don't
believe in science I don't want them
today it's like two really two people do
you know what we do exactly we're living
except don't get me started here Chuck
you like you can't even tell time you're
talking about you don't believe us you
can't even tell time I end up deciding
what a scientists
they put crap in the sky that
calculates the time that you can't even
tell that's that's what science does and
you got the nerve to sit around like oh
well you know because seriously do they
really know do they really I'm not sure
if they really know okay okay
whatever
that is that is just so I just love that
it's so elegant yeah in the fact that
it's
you know establishing the time but then
relaying the time
after it equates what the time will
actually be for you that's fresh
for you because it is touched by
Einstein's general theory relativity yes
oh that's just so good all right okay
that's so freaking cool man like what do
people think scientists do right right
do you think we're just sitting around
so cool
oh man all right all right next one here
we go this is Kyle Marston and Kyle says
um I know how I perceive the universe
and I know uh you and Neil you perceive
the universe as well and that our
perceptions are pretty similar as
biological entities from Earth what
insights do you have Neil uh as we now
have artificial intelligence how will
they perceive the universe around them
like
are they going to go straight to Dan
Simmons technical or more like
Tchaikovsky's Hive assembly
holy crap okay I'm telling you the truth
Kyle
I'm sorry I read your question
no I'm joking that's pretty wild yeah
okay so I have several ways to address
that one of them is I don't know that
people thought much about ai's sensory
system oh very nice right so can AI feel
pain I love it and can AI
um taste right
um right and but we know we can outfit
it with capacity to hear and to see that
is vastly greater than our own yeah all
right that self-driving cars we'll be
able to see it nice our senses these are
senses correct so so we can outfit AI
with sin I don't know that we can quite
have them taste things we'd have to why
not why not think about this no you're
olfactory sensors in your brain
basically are
um responding to a molecular stimuli yes
yes so why wouldn't we be able to
program what that molecular makeup is
and then give the computer the same yes
we can response however yes we can
however I we just have centuries of
efforts to improve our capacity of sight
with microscopes and telescopes and to
improve our capacity to hear with
sensory devices and microphone so so we
don't
we're much more behind in having
machines that can taste let's put it
that way okay I got you okay so so we
can have a machine that can analyze the
chemicals of what's touching a you know
there's mass spectrometers that can
analyze chemicals we can say if it's
this much that that's hey salty this
tastes sweet and this is the Umami we
could teach it that I guess sure but
then it has to sort of bite into you
right to to taste it right it has it
needs some mechanism to taste all right
right right it can't just be a box on
the table it'd be the difference between
someone telling you what something
tastes like correct and you putting it
in your mouth correct tasting it right
correct right all right and so uh
because you can hand them all the
ingredients that went into your pie
and then they can analyze those
ingredients and they say um good I want
some ice cream with that in a pi hour
mode they might do that but would they
want to right right right does AI have
our urges does AI have our you know
typically it's only thought of in terms
of problem solving and this sort of
thing not in terms of receiving the
sensory pleasures of what it is to be
alive
but let me add to that that in science
you know there are people who run around
saying I have a sixth sense
and they want you to be impressed with
that and I say well I'm a scientist and
I have a dozen senses
because I have sensors that can detect
all manner of things happening around me
that my five biological senses can't I
can detect polarization I have a
gravimeters that can detect slight
differences in where the mass is beneath
our feet I can have things I can have
devices that can detect radioactivity
that we cannot
sensorily do I can detect
um wavelengths of light that fall
outside of the visible spectrum all
right so I have dozens of Senses you're
not impressing me with your Sixth Sense
wow yeah so why don't you take that
little uh yet little parlor trick back
to your seance
okay I'm sensing someone who's passed
with the letter j
wow so yeah okay so that's cool I sent
someone here with a relative that has an
X in their name those those seers don't
last very long on the block that's so
funny yeah they never do that yeah
that's right well there you have it man
there you go so let me ask you this as a
follow-up to Kyle's question do you
think it's a good idea
to you know and not in a not as a means
of anthropomorphizing machines but do
you think there's any true benefit in
giving them our sense of taste and smell
whatever I want motion and whatever it
is I want them to think that humans
taste badly
it's people people it's
I don't want them thinking that we have
tasty snack that bag will not go
overwhelmed oh my God that's so great
that's very funny all right here we go
this is Christopher Fowler and he says
to serve man yeah that's right yes
exactly
super Fowler says
nice uh first I am just a huge fan of
yours Neil uh thank you for providing
the spark of curiosity to us commoners
uh second thinking about the Stargate
franchise could there be a discovery in
nuclear fusion advancements and
understanding and I use this term very
Loosely of the quantum being able to
establish an Einstein Rosen bridge for
interplanetary and Interstellar travel
wow so let me let me first agree that we
kind of need that if we're going to go
between the planets right and and no not
the point between the stars and Galaxy
yeah planets takes you know a dozen
years we can that's within a human
lifetime but to the nearest Stars
there's tens of thousands of years we
need a wormhole Stargate is basically a
wormhole they didn't call it that but
that's what it was and except there was
just this this this
metallic ring that you know it's mixed
with mysticism and magic and this sort
of thing
so you step into the ring like Time
Tunnel those who remember this from the
late 1960s you step into the ring and
you're transported through time the do
you know where they went in the very
first episode of typical I do not they
went to the Titanic
why and the guy's on the ship he's on
the deck of a ship and he's oh I'm on a
ship good because they got lost in time
right so he's on a ship and I wonder
where was that and and he walks by and
the camera moves with him and then the
camera moves back and you see the life
the buoy that says Titanic that's great
and you say oh because you know there
was not a second voyage of the Titanic
right so my boy is going down on this on
this trip and apparently they took a
poll about
um if you could move through time what
historical event would you want to
witness and many people said they wanted
to see the sinking of the Titanic so it
has been hypothesized that that's why
the Titanic sank
because when the time machine was
finally invented everyone went back to
the Titanic and there were too many
people for the lifeboats oh that's funny
because they were all time travelers and
they all died and you know what
time to the Titanic they deserved to die
no that's all I must say not pity right
all the places you can go you're like I
want to go back and see a bunch of
people drowns listen you know
I don't care how much you don't like
rich people
[Music]
a little too much carb to want to go
back to the Titanic you got what you
deserve you right on there with them
when it goes down okay I hope I hope
Leonardo's DiCaprio grabs you by the
head and pulls you right down with him
just like sorry Grace okay
are you done check I'm sorry I don't
know where that came from all right so
where were where was I thought coming so
it was just about the the the Stargate
the possible Stargate portal uh we know
how to make a we know what is required
to make a wormhole right we just don't
have this material so it needs something
it needs the equivalent of negative
gravity negative energy substance and we
don't know what that is or how to make
it but if we had it we can make it do it
there you go great question Chris thank
you yeah all right we got to take a
break Chuck and when we come back the
third and final segment of start talk
Cosmic queries grab bag Edition
on starcom
we're back start talking Cosmic query is
grab bag we left off that last segment
we were talking about Stargate Chuck do
you know I have a cameo in Stargate
Atlantis I did not know that now that
was the TV show yeah TV show oh man
what please tell me and now I gotta you
know I'm an old friend of one of the
characters and and I can't act so it's
embarrassing so I'm not I shouldn't have
told you no never mind okay let me tell
you why it's not embarrassing guess how
many appearances I have on Stargate
because it's a cameo people give you a
little more slack for your inability
it's so cool yeah yeah
please I can't act either and I've been
in a bunch of stuff
and I'm supposed to be an actor
higher that such okay I still can't act
so guess what all right you should be
very proud don't ever shoot please the
next one all right here we go this is
Jason uh White Terror uh who says um
greetings Dr Tyson Lord nice with the
expansion of the universe
likely never ending
and space-time with it
will individual galaxies be ripped apart
by the expansion as objects get further
apart from each other well individual
bodies be then ripped apart and so forth
yes what
ultimately as galaxies spread apart this
pressure within the vacuum of space we
call it dark energy we don't know what
it is but it's there and it's doing its
thing and it is most of what is driving
the universe right now that dark energy
I will ultimately overcome the
gravitational attraction of stars that
are held together within galaxies
so start ripping apart gouging then
it'll rip apart star systems as it pulls
planets away from their host stars then
it will rip apart solid objects as the
molecular bonds that hold the atoms
together are broken then it will rip
apart atoms where the electrons are
ripped from their nuclei then it will
rip apart nuclei then it'll rip apart
the fabric of space and time on the
plank scale
and at that point it's the end
that is called the Big Rip and that will
take place in 22 billion years unless
something stops it sleep well Timmy have
a nice day
God that's awful it starts ripping apart
protons themselves right this is this is
serious stuff
look at that and by the way when that
begins to happen it happens rapidly so
it's a you know what starts things
getting flying apart it's because the
more vacuum there is in the universe the
more is this pressure to accelerate it
gotcha right so it's it's a runaway
process so okay got you yeah right it's
it just it's like a snowball rolling
downhill correct boom boom boom bigger
bigger bigger bigger bigger bigger and
the bigger it is the bigger gas look at
that that is insane and it's called the
Big Rip
by the way in our second star talk book
guess what it was title Chuck uh no go
ahead Cosmic queries yes in our second
start talk book uh one of the questions
is what is the future of the universe
and we show all the scenarios that and
one of them is the Big Rip so if you get
that book you have way more conversation
about it than anything I just laid down
to this recording fantastic the cosmic
queries Cosmic queries you got it all
right so this is Bruce Ryan hey what's
up gents Bruce from Virginia here I'm
wondering what happens to all the heat
and energy emitted from Stars it's
actually
is it actually heating up the universe
or does it just travel until it hits
something and then that something
absorbs that heat and then what happens
when that I love it okay so both of
those happen
so what happened is the heat generated
from a star goes out in the form of
photons of light right okay and that
will travel until it hits something else
and then it gets absorbed so you'd think
it would just be this this tennis match
going on back and forth however
in the expanding Universe the energy of
the photon is diluted into the space
that has been expanded for it
[Music]
so the energy the total energy
okay the total energy is still there
but it's diluted
so another if you have a so have a box
of energy right now I take that energy
and spread it into a box twice that size
right it's the same amount of energy
but the energy intensity is now half in
each place
now make the Box a thousand times as
large all right that energy is all
spread out the energy intensity is
dropped by a factor of a thousand add it
all up you'll recover all the energy you
began with but the energy density is
thinner and as the universe expands the
energy density drops and so the
temperature of the universe drops and
right now we're three degrees Kelvin
three degrees absolute on the scale and
it's dropping look at that wow that's uh
by the way the James Webb Space
Telescope part of why we put it where it
is is that it's far away from Earth so
Earth it's a million miles from Earth
and it only ever points away from the
sun and it has these baffles
that will absorb some light that hits it
but re-radiate it back to the Sun
a little bit moves through whether we
have another baffle that will absorb it
and re-rade it back to the Sun and so we
have four or five of these layers
and each layer less and less of the
sun's heat energy makes it through to
Shield the telescope from any
um infrared energy that could hit it
from the Sun by shielding away the sun
it drops into equilibrium with deep
space
James Webb Coppertone that's
yeah I guess you can consider I guess it
is like sunscreen it's sunscreen it's
it's a cosmic sunscreen thank you Chuck
for that for that analogy and and so in
by doing so the sun which is relatively
close
to it all things considered will not
then heat it up
and so any heat that's in it'll just
radiate back out into space
so uh this is the thermodynamics uh
Technology and Engineering and in the
universe itself
wow wow yeah that is cool all right man
we're getting through a lot today yeah
look keep it coming I can't believe it
keep it coming this is Cameron Bishop he
says hey Neil hey Chuck I like to think
that if I waved at the night sky
someone out there in the distant past
is waving back
now in the last century we have gone
from Stars might have planets to stars
on average have lots of planets if you
run the numbers the amount of planets
out there is huge given that we exist
it's not fair to say that with life here
on Earth in one hand and the amount of
planets in the universe on the other
hand that life is statistically likely
in the universe and what sort of
implications does that have either
scientifically or philosophically
the day we discover Life in the universe
it will signal a change in the human
condition that we cannot foresee or
imagine
yes it is highly likely that life is
thriving elsewhere in the universe not
out of wishful thinking but we're made
of the most common ingredients in the
universe
so whatever life was doing on Earth it
was highly opportunistic a b life got
going almost as fast as it possibly
could have within a hundred million
years this sounds like long but it's
short on the time scale of Earth within
100 million years we went from organic
molecules which are plentiful in the
universe to self-replicating life
and the universe is old
so you combine how long how much time
we've had how quickly Earth managed to
create life how resourceful life is and
to assert that we're alone in the
universe can only be done based on some
philosophy that has no foundation in
science
yeah it is that's it man that's it
that's it and so if you wave surely
someone is waving back I have no doubt
yeah that's it and your waiver's not
going to get to them right for you know
100 or a thousand light you know years
traveling at the speed of light what I
do every time I'm out and I have my
laser I flash it at a star that's in the
night sky
like a like a pulse and then I turn it
off so if you leave the light on for one
second all right there's a beam that's
186 000 miles long
right okay and so that is on its way to
that to that star and maybe to a planet
that'll see it it's so cool yeah that's
just my it's my space graffiti I'd say
Neil is here and so when when they show
up so I want to get picked up I want to
I want to meet the elephant when they
show up and they're just like we saw
your green signal
that was our Man Neil uh yes and by the
way you are now all serving our God Farm
what
yeah Chuck desperately wants to write a
screenplay that's clear
it'd be kind of cool though if like they
landed and they were on their version of
what we had as the Crusades oh no except
that they do it on an Intergalactic base
yeah yeah okay you know
anyway all right Tyler J says hello Dr
Tyson hi and where did they say where
they're from I always want to know uh
what options are there to resolve the
crisis in cosmology I heard that new
data from James Webb Space Telescope has
further separated the two values we have
for the Hubble constant
yeah
yeah this crisis is by the way when I
was coming of age I mean astrophysically
uh we didn't know the size of the
universe to within a factor of two the
size or the age of the universe right so
within a factor of two to show you how
precise modern cosmology has become okay
we are now arguing over a 10 difference
between two numbers
and the reason why it's called a crisis
is each of those two numbers is
precisely known
so that there the the error bars the you
know the uncertainties do not overlap
right so that's even though they're
close to each other especially compared
to when I was in school they don't
overlap and so it's called a crisis in
cosmology and crisis I think overstates
it it's a it's an unsolved problem
every unsolved problem is not a crisis
it's just an unsolved problem right and
but somebody's wrong
okay
very good so and that's the answer
somebody is wrong and and the more
you're measuring two different things
and you think it's the same thing
exactly okay yeah you can measure the
tail of an element to the blind man and
the feet and the tusks and the trunk
and you could tell each other that each
the other person is wrong
but maybe you're measuring the same
thing but in different parts in
different ways and collectively you all
are describing one object and it's the
elephant exactly you're both describing
the universe but maybe you came at it
from different sides of the elephant
about that so I'm not worried about it
it makes good headlines yeah I'm not
worried about it yes James Webb will
help us address this yes that's
fantastic uh that's wonderful by the way
I think in Cosmic queries we do talk
about the crisis
the cosmic uh I think it's in there in
the in the future of the universe
cosmology right right
it's it's called Uh tension it's called
a cosmic tension tension between these
two different measurements so again in
Cosmic queries I hate to sound like a ad
for the book but yeah I mean it is an ad
for the book we put a lot of effort into
that book yeah and Christ is in
cosmology not to be confused with the
crisis in cosmetology okay
how dare you put that eye shadow with
that lip color no no you know the crisis
in cosmetologies I wrote about this in
in story messenger okay and alien comes
to visit
and they see yes that people will with
straight hair
curl it people with curly hair
straighten their hair people who are
short wear heels people who uh if their
body is not the muscles aren't big
enough they try to make them bigger if
they're but there's something else about
their body they'll get they'll change it
they they they do all these things and
so the aliens will say
you guys must deeply believe that you
are irreconciliably
ugly right
given how much money is spent on the
beauty industrial complex they uh they'd
be right they'd be right they
they be right if they were to make those
uh assessments because they're not even
assumptions right just assessments yeah
you got the you got you've got eyelash
thickener what you don't like your
eyelashes you got uh um a powder on your
cheeks what you're you don't like the
color of your cheeks you you you know
you've got you've got paint around your
eye your eyelids and you don't like the
color of your what so yeah they'll run
back home and say there's no sign of
intelligent life on Earth plus they all
think they're ugly well right you might
think I think I'm ugly maybe I just
think I'm fabulous
all right I don't think we have time for
anyone throw one more if I have time
I'll do it go okay let me just let me
find something very quick I'm gonna you
don't know how quick my answer is gonna
be well I'm gonna make it a quick
question okay good wait okay so here we
go
hello Neil and Chuck from NAU in
Flagstaff I was wondering if you've
heard or know about the idea of black
hole Stars
I've seen videos taking this
hypothetical hypothetical star that has
an insane mass and it could explain
black holes in the middle of galaxies I
asked you this question I didn't realize
in a weird a few weeks ago but any
thoughts on that hmm
yeah I don't know what a black hole star
would be other than just a star that
became a black hole exactly right I
don't know you know we have very clear
definitions of stars that we know of
nothing that has the mass that would
create the black holes that we see at
the center of gas oh correct yeah that's
still a that's an unknown we don't know
what phenomenon is necessary to funnel
Mass to whatever black hole began there
for it to become to have hundreds of
millions of times the mass of the sun
it's it's still and James Webb is going
to help us figure that out figure that
out well it's a frontier there you go
and notice I'm not calling it a crisis
it's just something we don't understand
yeah exactly right right we don't get
all emotional about it it's just let's
work on it yeah so there you go pull
yourself together man put yourself
together you can get through this you'll
get through this man put yourself
together
all right Chuck that's all we got that's
all we got time for that's it I love
grab bags those are fun okay yeah
Cosmic queries grab bag Chuck always
good to have you there always a clip the
old the grass Tyson here for snartalk
Cosmic queries
[Music]